Hello little turtles and Octopi coffee
on a Tuesday and blog,
at night.
I often wonder what I imagined is not an
uncommon reverie.
If there are aliens out there on planets
orbiting distant stars looking up and
wondering the exact same thing.
If they have evolved like us to build
massive powerful telescopes,
they of course see turning the lens in
our direction,
the great spiral that is the Milky Way,
a kind of motion in celestial stillness,
but that's not all dates.
Zooming out a bit more,
they'd catch a pair of bright clouds
looking almost like children chasing
each other in empty space around their
parent galaxy.
Older and larger sibling would appear
about a 10th as bright as the Milky Way
and the smaller siblings about a fourth,
as bright as that.
These are the magellanic clouds just to
have over a dozen satellite galaxies are
orbiting the Milky Way.
What makes these two so distinct is that
unlike their brethren,
there are still alive with the materials
necessary for making stars.
In fact,
the larger Magellanic cloud is so
fertile,
it boasts the largest stellar nursery in
our local group.
Beating out the vastly bigger Andromeda
galaxy and even our own Milky Way.
Most galactic satellites are dead in
this respect.
The Gargantuan Gravitational Force of
the parent galaxy usually robs them of
their gas in a process known as titled,
stripping.
Without gas,
there can be no stars.
These dark dwarf steroidals are the
haunted houses.
Have a galactic subgroups,
so faintly do they move across the sky
that the first one discovered the
sculptor tour in 1938,
was mistaken for a fingerprint on a
photographic plate.
Why then or the Magellanic cloud still
viable?
Well,
new data from the Hubble is starting to
reveal some clues.
Yellow astronomer,
each a colleague whose name I've just
murdered,
says that there are likely passing us
for the very first time.
This means their orbits once thought to
be one to 2 billion years around the
Milky Way might be much,
much longer.
They only got close to us.
It seemed some 200 million years ago,
which is to say just now,
for all that previous time they were as
the man indeed and astronomer named
Martina Bates,
left from Columbia University thinks
that the smaller cloud actually smashed
right through the larger initiating an
accelerated star creation and leaving
many of its own stars
behind.
And you know,
as I was reading this article in
scientific American from which I learned
many of these things,
I had a thought.
I was thinking how noteworthy it is that
the mechanics of nature so mimic the
emotional mechanics of our lives.
I mean,
have you ever
smashed right into somebody?
Have you move through someone and not
afterwards retained some of their own
stars?
Do we not like these brilliant clouds
leave a trail of ourselves in the wake
of our movement through the world?
What is this parallelism between nature
and humanity?
I began to think the mighty heaven says,
the philosopher PROC lists exhibits in
its transfigurations clear images of the
splendor of intellectual perceptions.
And as the Magellanic clouds move closer
in their transit to the Milky Way,
the nearer is pulled away from its
partner and left at such a distance,
as would make it impossible for the
dance to continue.
The lesser fractured from its earlier
collision will hurdle in the dark to a
gas lists fate and empty nursery,
some haunted fingerprint on the
photographic plate.
The Universe is the externalization of
the soul wherever the life is that
bursts into appearance around it.
Our science is central and therefore
superficial.
The earth and the heavenly bodies,
physics and chemistry,
we sensually treat as if they were self
existent.
But these are the retinue of the being
that we have.
Emerson,
the poet.